le 17 novembre 2018 des centaines de
milliers de français vêtue d'un gilet
jaune manifestent contre l'instauration
d'une nouvelle taxe sur les carburants
le début d'un mouvement qui va avoir des
revendications beaucoup plus large et
qui va durer plusieurs mois
comme ici à montceau les mines souvenez
vous
[Applaudissements]
on est à deux affaires à travailler doit
travailler
on paye notre salaire tout ce qu'on
entend dire comme taxes pour n'en peut
plus - la fin du mois on est toujours à
moins quelque chose le pouvoir d'achat
diminué g4g quatre petits enfants
on sait pas comment on va faire pour
leur acheter des cadeaux à noël afin de
nous ponctionner ponctionner fonctionner
il va plus vient de rester
[Musique]
ça fait assez longtemps et c'est déjà
avant ma chronique
on entend une grogne qui perdure et qui
est latente et
je me suis bien imaginer qu'on aurait là
à nouveau un espèce de mai 68 qui
pointait le nez à l'horizon
après l'échangeur du magny c'est sur ce
parking que les îles et jaune de
montceau les mines on est établi leur
campement
pierre gaël laveder vous êtes un de ses
sites et zones aujourd'hui a plus rien
si bien sûr les gilets jaunes du magny
continue de se réunir sur ce parking pas
avec autant de personnes qui a deux ans
en arrière mais toujours une bonne
vingtaine de personnes viennent ici
régulièrement
si on fait le bilan deux ans plus tard
ce mouvement il a servi à quoi le
mouvement il a permis déjà l'ensemble
des travailleurs qui étaient précaires
de pouvoir s'exprimer puisqu'il n'avait
pas vraiment des espaces d'expression au
sein de la société
on peut dire la même chose et retraités
des commerçants et des artisans qui sont
venus grossir le mouvement puisque à
montceau les mines on était jusqu à 2000
ici sur l'échangeur et les parmi les
conséquences on a forcément eu un recul
d'un certain nombre de mesures comme la
taxe carbone
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'à un moment le
mouvement simple mais tout ça c'est un
peu digues les la première chose qui a
provoqué la diminution du nombre de gens
qui sont venus ce dans n'importe quelle
rond-point des gilet jaune ou dans
n'importe quelle rue de france dans les
grandes métropoles c'était la violence
policière
le deuxième effet kiss cool c'est à dire
plus on rassemble de gens au même
endroit mais ça on l'a vu partout sur la
planète dans tous les mouvements sociaux
plus le nombre de revendications
augmente la multiplication du nombre de
revendications a fait fuir un certain
nombre de gens qui étaient venus
uniquement pour la taxe carbone
nous allons également à la rencontre de
deux autres gilet jaune de la première
heure nous retrouvons fanny morales et
un restaurateur michel lacroix dont nous
avions dressé le portrait en décembre
ce sexagénaire a racheté ce bistrot il y
à sept ans après une carrière de
chauffeur poids lourd depuis il se
dégage le même salaire que son personnel
1200 euros par mois demain michel a donc
prévu de se rendre aux côtés des gilet
jaune avec un repas chaud à leur offrir
c'est ici quelques kilomètres plus loin
que les gilet jaune pourront apprécier
le repas de michel en majorité des
retraités dans un pays minier
mineurs se sont toujours beaucoup aidé
dans les coups durs quand ils ont fait
les grèves parce que ça les gens l'ont
peut-être un peu oublié mais les mineurs
quand ils ont fait les grèves ils se
sont toujours entre aider mais c'est ça
vous fait quoi de revoir ces images
ça fait plaisir ça me met un peu ça
m'émeut un peu parce que c'est vrai que
moi je suis à fond dans le mouvement
parce qu'il ya une très grande
différence entre une partie de personnes
et une autre partie il ya les gens il
faut les aider si si ils sont sur la
route dans les rues
c'est bien qu'il ya un problème mais je
suis parti mais à l'inversé de maths a
besoin parce qu'on sait pas comment les
choses vont tourner faut pas hésiter à
faire appel
moi mon grand regret c'est un moment
donné au tout départ de chez les jaunes
d'oeufs de cette ville a titré en tant
que politique alors qu'en fait on aurait
dû se dire ah partisans parce qu'en
réalité au quotidien on fait de la
politique tous c'est aujourd'hui une
grosse déception de voir que les gens ne
sont plus dans la rue maintenant les
gens en fait continue beaucoup
l'expression et le mouvement par les
réseaux sociaux jusqu'à toujours les
mêmes choses j'espère qu'on arrivera à
aboutir à ce qui est plus ces inégalités
sociales énormes
et surtout qu'on ait plus cette angoisse
pour nos enfants de voir que le monde et
la france donc par dans des directions
horrible enfin voilà qui a pas d'avenir
et dans le travail
en plus on est dans une région voilà on
a aussi beaucoup lutté les derniers mois
sur des fermetures d'usinés dans notre
secteur
le feu on va dire gilet jaune il est pas
éteint et peut être encore des bruits
il reste encore plus que des braises et
il en faut peu pour qu'elle se rallume
mais ça vaut le coup de continuer parce
que
voilà ça crée aussi une fraternité des
solidarités on a revu des gens vraiment
cédé l'entr'aide on a remis un sens à ce
mot et ça vaut le coup de continuer à se
battre
deux ans après des premières
manifestations il est toujours difficile
de définir précisément qui sont les
idées jaune et ce qu'il souhaite à
plusieurs reprises le mouvement a tenté
de retrouver la flamme sans jamais
atteindre des influences des premières
semaines
aujourd'hui avec la crise sanitaire et
ses conséquences certains pensent que
c'est encore possible